all right we're back again and [ __ ]
crashed
so you have no idea what the [ __ ] it was
it just froze yeah
i mean you know it was that sexual
tyrannosaur hat it was the
sexual tyrannosaur energy it was all the
[ __ ] we were talking about all these
[ __ ] clandestine operations
we said the wrong things and the
algorithm just went ah [ __ ] no
they're they're maybe it's because you
said that girl was in a cup and someone
got offended yeah that's what it is that
girl's a cup
that's it maybe that girl made it stop
yeah because she was like my bones
aren't small
no she was cute though yeah she was good
she had nice boobs yeah you know for
for a dead person yeah thank goodness
if they [ __ ] cut the stream because
of that joke then these [ __ ]
these [ __ ] no
i'm just
because i think that was like the last
thing that you said before it crashed
probably or you know what i mean so no
boobs are going to show up
i think it's i think the ai's listening
to me though they're like
they're like look like i started talking
about breasts is we're gonna have to
cutting this is this is this is family
hours
that we're here in the family the
internet does not have family viewing
hours
well nothing has failed entirely
you don't you know yeah like i said it's
it's midnight somewhere
on the screen so you know but i think
what i was saying
before this [ __ ] started going all
pear-shaped yeah okay
was yeah was that ironically
even though the director robert wise
didn't want michael crichton
to adapt it because he thought oh he'll
be mad if we make any changes
the guy that they got to adapt it made
it almost exactly like the novel
i think the only changes they made were
they gender swapped one of the
scientists like because they all the
scientists were dudes in the book so
they made one of them a woman
um which was kind of fun like robert
wise didn't want to do
it but then like the writer was like
well yeah but you know
why it doesn't have to be a total
sausage fest or whatever and this is
like 1971.
and then the thing about it though is
that i think that character
the one female doctor i think she was
actually the most interesting character
yeah but one thing that the she looked
like a scientist yeah and i thought that
was kind of cool well they actually
consulted like actual female scientists
um they looked like well not so much to
see what they look like but just to see
what the vibe was
no no because if you had the average
[ __ ] on there he'd get the
hottest woman he could find
that's what i think i think that robert
wise i don't think he was
averse to there being a woman scientist
in the movie he said i don't want it to
be like a raquel welch and
a scientist and it would have been like
that although they did that into the
[ __ ] 90s and 2000s too it's like he
couldn't just have a woman
scientist that looked like a person they
had to be like a super hot model and
also a scientist and i'm like no one
buys that what are you trying to say
models aren't people
no well no i'm not saying that it's just
that people have
people have perceptions you know what i
mean that's like
that's like these people cracking down
these dudes crap trying to crack down
on anime go on what is up with all these
boobs these builds
women are not built like that and one of
these [ __ ]
cosplay model girls [ __ ] posts a
picture and goes oh yes we are and she's
in that same [ __ ] outfit
those same proportions yeah they're it's
all out there
yeah it's all about well yeah people can
look like anything
and you know but what the thing is is a
[ __ ]
a biological warfare level
scientist no she's not going to look
like that she's probably not because
she's
like got better things to do than like
sit there and do the hair and the makeup
and all that kind of stuff
it depends on what your value systems
are well yeah it won't exactly
what's better well exactly i'm just
saying that if you're assigned she's
probably busy
it's always all over because the dudes
that are doing that that you they're
lame
mostly well the thing about it though is
like i like
that they did that and she was actually
the i think she was actually the most
interesting character because she was
funny and snarky and [ __ ] like that's
what they would call back in the day at
battle axe
she was kind of but but in an
entertaining way like i thought she was
really funny
she was always like making cracks and
stuff which i thought was awesome
but they did actually kind of one thing
that they did was that
they kind of took all the annoying uh
personality quirks of
all the characters in the book and put
them all on her you know what i mean
because i feel like it the the annoying
characters were kind of spread out more
i was i was watching a a thing that was
about the book
and they said there's like not a single
likable character in this everyone's
kind of an [ __ ]
um but it was but everyone was like up
like equal opportunity
[ __ ] like they were all like really
unlikable but it seemed like in the
movie
like the dude characters were kind of
you know likable or inoffensive but then
like all the they took all the [ __ ]
tendencies and put them on the one woman
which that was kind of funny but like i
said it kind of worked in its favor
because i ended up thinking that she was
the most interesting character the other
the other dudes were kind of boring but
um yeah and i was watching another
review and the guy that was talking
about this
said that this was actually one of his
favorite sci-fi movies from the 70s
but he said and i don't say this about a
lot of movies but he said this is one
where even though all the acting and
characters and stuff are good
you could completely change them out for
different people and it would still work
because it's not
a character-based story it's a plot
based
story it's a you know you're worried
about the plot and the mystery and
everything like that not
mission based yeah it's not so much
about the people
it's kind of kind of like a uh in in
some ways similar to a a real good
episode of star trek
where it's not the characters it's the
mission they're trying to get it done
that's that that's kind of the story
yeah yeah it's good
and that's what it is it is what it is
just pepper says uh it doesn't have to
be a total sausage fest like i said she
says me
in my actual science career and then she
says no jenny gods we wake up three
hours earlier than the male scientists
to look good
yeah there's that too um i will say like
i said this movie came out in 1971
and there are no
computer effects in it other than the
regular
you know [ __ ] that you see on the screen
like you know back in 1971 it was just
like little green
like teletype kind of [ __ ] on there but
they show some kind of computery looking
[ __ ]
like the computer graphics like of you
know like a 3d model and stuff like that
yeah it's called vectorscope [ __ ]
graphics but it wasn't vector
they didn't do that with a computer um
they actually did that like
photographically
like they layered all these different
like they filmed an actual thing and
then like they did all the layers and
stuff
and then they didn't have the computer
technology right vector scope so it
looked really cool and all
and a lot of the [ __ ] that they see
because a lot of hat of the [ __ ] has to
do with them like this
studying this pathogen like under the
microscope like an increasing uh you
know magnification
and that was all real [ __ ] like they
they so so they did it all as
realistically as possible
just goes to show you how far we've gone
in technology
to getting to do some of this [ __ ] in
this super secret underground base you
had to put your hand on there and it
read your fingerprints and they had to
explain to the audience to each other
that it was reading your fingerprints
and i'm going down my tablet does that
yeah yeah i mean
yeah people's bones do it you had to
make a big deal out of it you know
but uh yeah 1971 that was pretty high
tech yeah
but the uh the animated sequences of
what the computer is doing and what the
internal layout you know they're trying
to show you the layout of the complex
it does look like computer graphics but
it isn't but yes it did a pretty good
job
of illustrating what future graphics
would look like it was pretty accurate
yeah it was 10 years later in the 80s
that's the kind of stuff you'd see
late 80s and when the computer was like
it would have been 20 years ahead
and when they showed the andromeda you
know the crystal
structure like multiplying or whatever
it was doing
that was actually that wasn't computer
generated either that was an actual
object that they had that they could
like kind of fold out and stuff
you know what i mean like it was kind of
like one of those toys like a jacob's
ladder toy i think they called it
and they folded out and filmed it in
like weird ways and put like different
effects on it and [ __ ]
so they did everything like
photographically because they didn't
have uh
you know they didn't have all the
computer technology also another fun
fact that i didn't realize
but you know how in the movie the you
know the the facility is what like five
stories deep right
so each level is a different color and
you have to go through ever more
stringent
uh decontamination like as you go down
and so the set that they have like this
kind of round said it's kind of star
trek-y looking or whatever
um the hallways it's actually all one
set
but they just shot all the stuff like
for the red room and then they repainted
everything yellow and then they redid it
at the same set for the yellow
yeah and i was like well that's that's
very uh cost effective but yeah that's
what they did
and everything was uh the concept behind
the secret
bio laboratory was all kind of
pretty badass i mean it's kind of [ __ ]
that if they don't have it that's the
way it should be
if it when they had all these protocols
and procedures if they lost containment
the thing had a self-destruct mechanism
it would just flood itself full of
[ __ ] gas wouldn't it
the flammable gas and just burn and kill
everybody well there was a nuclear bomb
nuclear bomb in the bottom that's what
it was
because remember that was like the big
thing at the end was that blew itself up
they were kind of like um because the
people were like oh [ __ ]
you know the the contamination stuff
goes off automatically
and if that one guy didn't go in there
and put that other key into the thing
then the whole thing would [ __ ] blow
up
yeah the whole thing was is that you
could take a disease down in there and
if there was any chance that you that it
was getting out it would just [ __ ]
like set off an atomic bomb
well because i mean and then and then
when they went down there they knew that
they might actually have to do that
like if it but then they found out later
on in the movie
that andromeda was actually took
energy like it fed on energy right it
also ate plastic and [ __ ] like that too
but
it fed on energy so if you hit it with a
nuclear bomb it would just make it
proliferate like even more
more of it would appear so at that point
you know they were like oh it's going to
get out so we're going to like
turn on the [ __ ] bomb but then they
were like no no no we have to turn the
bomb off and so like there was this kind
of racism it was made
it was made to destroy the biological
material and this wasn't really like
bio carbon-based life it was it was
it was silicone-based yes which was kind
of a big thing like
because i remember that being a real big
thing in science fiction like back then
and i think michael crichton
had read something about that like about
crystal-based life forms you know
theoretically
and he got really interested in that
because it's almost like something
that's like alive but not alive like
almost like a virus but not quite
like it doesn't have any living which is
like it's inorganic but it still
reproduces and stuff
um the only thing that i'm not a fan of
this movie
is that i don't like how it ends
because it almost seems like there's all
this work and there's all this stuff and
then
should i say what happened like what
like what the end is like how they went
i don't spoil it
it just seems a little bit like a too
easy
solution you know what i mean like a
deus ex machina type of
type of thing where it's just kind of
like oh
that was lucky how that happened you
know what i mean yeah that kind of bugs
me a little there was also like
uh some stuff where it kind of it as the
story unfolds it turns out that
that that they had andromeda and they
were trying to weaponize it
they were doing weapons research it was
from space
from space but they were gonna they were
gonna work with it yeah and
and see what they could do you know in
terms of making that
a weapon in which you know the
scientists were like wait a minute hold
on you know that's
what that's not the mission but it
that's what happened
you know what i mean of course they're
gonna monkey around with that [ __ ]
speaking of monkeys and rats um
when i was watching this movie because
there is a lot of like animal
experimentation
in this like not you know not
vivisection or anything like that but
they do kind of show
um some rats and they haven't been
occasionally and supposedly in the movie
they're
you know uh exposing them to andromeda
then they're dying or whatever
obviously they didn't really kill the
animals but
because i was sitting there going how
the [ __ ] did they do that because i saw
at the beginning that they said the
aspca like monitored everything it was
fine like the animals weren't harmed or
anything
but they did actually i think what they
did was they put them
they like either they gassed them with
carbon dioxide i think
yeah and then you see that monkey
holding on for rich
just to make him pass out yeah
to consciousness
yeah yeah even some of the rats i
thought maybe they hit him with some
chloroform or something
but they yeah they did something kind of
similar so i don't know if you'd be able
to get away with that nowadays um but in
the seven years right now
yeah because that seems a little well
you'd probably legally get away with it
it's just
they wouldn't i don't think they would
they wouldn't do it for they wouldn't do
it for a movie
i mean because you don't know what could
go wrong you know what i mean you might
actually kill the animal on that one
those are racist monkeys anyway i mean
you know i know but all the time in
laboratories i know but that's
i don't really like that either no movie
yeah and especially not just for a movie
i mean you know yeah you could make the
argument if they're you know trying to
like come up with a cure for something
it's like i don't
love it then either but you have there's
more justification
yeah there's at least more justification
but for a movie [ __ ] that is you know
you don't kill animals just because i
a lot of that [ __ ] i didn't i didn't
agree with because like some of that
[ __ ] that they were doing
back in the 60s and 70s is that they
were doing product testing
on monkeys yeah when there was no reason
to know
this well what happens if this shampoo
gets into the monkey's eye
let's put let's put shampoo in the
monkey's eye every hour
yeah it's like why would you that's like
horrible they were afraid of [ __ ]
lawsuits and you know if it was
dangerous or not but the thing is those
if it gets in your eye you wash your eye
out it's gonna be all right
okay yeah there's no reason we gotta
give it to the damn monkeys to prove
that i mean unless you put a
hydrochloric acid in that shampoo
i'm sure it'll probably be fine there's
just some water
but they don't do that anymore that's
that's could have been a grift too there
might have been companies that would
scare
other companies look we will test this
for you for a certain amount of money
and that'll save you from lawsuits if
you don't you're gonna get sued
maybe they would actually send somebody
to sue them
like a grift yeah maybe yeah a lot of
this [ __ ] wasn't really all that
on the up and up test with us or we'll
make sure you get sued
yeah okay yeah test it you know
esther said i love your shirt jenny
thank you this might
i always forget about it because it's
like because i have so many t-shirts i
got this at a horror convention a long
time ago
tequila i have another one too that's
like a like a beer one
yeah oracle says animal testing for
cosmetics is stupid evil it is
yeah it's a it's like unnecessary yeah
you don't need it
and i mean you know yeah a few people
are gonna have allergic reactions to it
but not enough to like
like i said as long as pretty much they
know what's certain
well what does what what does what yeah
so it's kind of like
like i said unless you're putting
sulfuric acid in the [ __ ] which you
shouldn't be doing anyway protip
um and you know probably it'll be fine
there's always going to be a small
percentage they're going to have
allergic reactions to that but you can't
control that because everybody's
different so you know what i mean even
with something perfectly safe you're
going to have somebody will have a damn
reaction reaction to it yeah because
like i said just everybody's
different so as long as that's minimized
and you know no one's growing a third
head or a third head
yeah you need to grow a second one
before you grow
oral said yeah the testing on for
cosmetics was [ __ ] stupid
yeah it was [ __ ] stupid yeah i mean i
can understand [ __ ] doing cancer
research that's very different yeah
you know but just you know right like i
said just makeup or [ __ ] like that
all right do we have anything else we
need to discuss about the movie
yeah it's a decent move it's good yeah
like i said know what you're going into
because it is a very
i mean it seems very modern i guess even
though it's very 70s at the same time
um but it's a very hard science
procedural
type of movie it's not real
action-packed it's not there's it's very
dialogue heavy
and it's kind of all centered around the
mission or them figuring out like what
this thing is and why it does what it
does
kind of reminds me of uh 2001 yeah it
has that same kind of vibe to it
i think there was a there was like kind
of a little mini boomlet of like movies
kind of like that in the
70s i feel like late 60s early 70s
maybe people had more patience back then
they were just like yeah
because this did actually pretty well i
think yeah you know
and the book was like a huge bestseller
and the book is almost exactly like the
movie other than a couple tiny little
details
well i think you know movies like this
were new back then
um people people were just starting to
to kind of like um become aware
of what governments and and contract the
contracted [ __ ] companies and what
they were doing in terms of science
yeah you know weapons science and
weapons technology you know that's all
part of it
and how all that's handled that whole
scene it does kind of have a little bit
of a
almost like a space program feel to it
like something about
the the damn moon mission like like a
viking mission it's kind of
feels like that like you're seeing a
movie about going to the moon
yeah it kind of looks it almost has a
little bit of a documentary field yeah
like i said so because that's how that's
what they decided they decided to do it
kind of like a documentary it's kind of
instructive
trying to show you kind of you know yeah
bio
bio weapons research kind of [ __ ]
plausible you know not plausible kind of
relevant to
to today with uh you know [ __ ] that's
happened in china involving
little jabs and things that you can't
talk about on youtube or you might lose
the stream
you know things of where they came from
did they come from over there in
china or okay that's all i'm gonna say
about it
they're gonna cook the ai will get me
yeah okay
yeah um yeah esther says great movie
that got me interested in sci-fi movies
yeah it is actually if you like
like hard sci-fi you definitely should
see it because it's one of the best
sci-fi movies in the 70s
dom the bomb says jenny have you seen
the new mini series of the stand and
what did you think and as
i know i haven't watched it yet i've
heard mixed things about it like some
people thought it was like really really
good some people
really like it i'm not really sure maybe
but i've seen so like some other
channels reviewing but
there's another movie that kind of
reminded me of this i mean i like the
demon seed was a little bit like this
but
the demon seat was a little more [ __ ]
fanciful
yeah i think i liked the demon seed a
little bit better
but similar yeah this one's not fanciful
at all
this is completely grounded and brutal
it's it's not real it's fiction
yeah but it's completely rather reality
like this one check out demon seed
it's about ai we did a review of that
one like a while back
ai what if ai went out of [ __ ]
control like back in the 70s they had
they had a super computer called proteus
made on it
it had brain material grown from
rats on the damn chips
and they became sentient and they were
corporations were [ __ ] hiring it
so having it contracted out to solve
[ __ ] problems like how to mine things
from the bottom of the ocean and
everything
well this thing just says [ __ ] this i
don't want to do it
it's a pretty good movie yeah pretty
good movie um
danny rowland ghostbase says uh this
reminds me of that jack lemmon film the
china syndrome yeah i think
yeah i haven't seen that a long time
either in a long time i forgot about
that
also another one that uh michael
crichton like another michael crichton
adaptation that we should probably do
uh at some point is coma you know what i
mean because i really like that one and
i haven't seen that
i haven't seen that one in a long time
and then oracle said there's a movie
called embryo have y'all seen that i
don't
think so but i don't know that seems
like another one that
i probably would have seen but i don't
remember what it is if i did
all right so you ready to wrap it up for
me today all right so
tonight we will watch another movie and
we'll come back tomorrow and talk about
it i'm not sure which one i have a
couple that
picked out so we'll see which one we
feel like watching later
so uh we will see you guys tomorrow at
three o'clock thanks everybody for
dropping by
have a good rest of your day and we'll
see you guys tomorrow afternoon
bye